[Música]
vivemos em relação não é uma escolha que
temos
a gente nasce já vai descobrindo o mundo
pela relação com a nossa mãe ou pela
falta dela
a relação com os nossos primeiros
cuidadores
a gente vai crescendo e essa vai se
expandindo a relação com os nossos
amigos com os familiares professores e
colegas as pessoas que a gente tromba na
rua e mesmo quem queira se isolar porque
cansou totalmente das pessoas da
humanidade vai lá primeira floresta vai
ter que se relacionar com as águas com
as plantas com o solo vai ter que
aprender a ler o ambiente
nós vivemos em relação e não é uma
escolha que a gente tem a gente tá junto
nessa gente divide ainda que de forma
desigual
o mesmo planeta mas a gente vive numa
sociedade que coloca todo o sistema de
valor ea própria existência em torno do
eu
o que eu quero o que eu gosto o que eu
penso o que eu falo o que eu mereço a
minha trajetória os meus medos os meus
sonhos
a gente é estimulado assim desde pequena
praticamente a única coisa que importa
eu e na história do eu a gente está
sempre correndo atrás sempre focando no
que tem - a gente está cansado a gente
acha que tem pouco na história do eu a
gente quer que as pessoas sejam iguais a
nós e aí a gente cria essas avaliações e
julgamentos e expectativas baseado em
como eu sou e aí tendo sempre eu como
referência
não à toa a gente se sente
incompreendido eu falo e não estão
entendendo o mundo tá ficando chato a
gente reclama quando vem uma opinião que
confronta eu e aí o ímpeto e se juntar
com os iguais ou se fechar
a gente briga agente excluir as redes da
vida a gente anula a gente faz piada
o eu que tem força econômica e moral
ou social impõe o seu jeito sobre os
demais
a gente cria padrões e uma idéia de
igualdade que só profunda problema
parece que não tá dando muito certo
afinal a gente vive em relação não é uma
escolha que a gente tem
então se a gente contasse uma história
de nós uma história de nós o euro perde
um pouco essa importância a gente
desloca a nossa atenção também para o
outro e para as nossas inúmeras relações
e quando a gente desloca a atenção para
outra e talvez a gente perceba o que é
bem óbvio mas que a gente ainda tem
bastante dificuldade de assumir diz em
voz alta que é somos diferentes
até tem quem se distraia dizendo que
somos todos humanos para dizer que somos
todos iguais mas não somos somos muito
diferentes e uma história de nós o que a
gente precisa então é aprender a
conviver com essa diferença porque esse
tanto de opinião diferente aponta é uma
diversidade grande de realidades e cada
vez mais pessoas estão falando como se
sentem o que pensam como é a sua
realidade expondo as suas intimidades e
essas vozes vão trazendo à tona
questionamentos que escancaram muitos
outros jeitos de ser muito mais plural
do que um jeito único certo doeu e com
mais gente falando de realidades que a
gente desconhece e não entende o maior
desafio é ouvir mas não é aquele ouvir
que é que estou deixando você falar
enquanto aqui na minha cabeça está
preparando uma resposta super ótimo é um
argumento incrível e se daqui agora ela
não vai deixar passar
isso sou eu o meu argumento é uma
história de nós é ouvir com a abertura
se permitir permear pelo outro seja quem
for o outro reconhecer como legítimo
como quem tem algo a dizer como quem tem
algo a ensinar ea partir desse tipo de
escuta criar um ambiente de confiança em
que as pessoas possam ser livres para
elas mesmas país porque elas acham ainda
que a gente discórdia e além do conteúdo
do eu acho isso eu acho aquilo a gente
concorda a gente discorda pra olhar para
a forma como a gente conversa
só que esse tipo de escuta é muito
difícil porque esse tipo de escuta
desperta na gente um monte de coisa ruim
incomoda e gera muito desconforto e aí a
gente se percebe se consegue ainda
segurar a onda e manter essa abertura a
gente percebe esse incômodo um conflito
não só com o outro mas um conflito com a
gente mesmo
eu vivi alguns conflitos pessoais
a mudança de trabalho de um universo
corporativo para um espaço de trabalho
fez mais sentido pra mim foi um deles
mas recentemente eu me reconheci como
mulher eu entendi o que significa nessa
sociedade do eu é que eu sempre tive
liberdade de tv e de escolha
profissional tive boas oportunidades
profissionais tive espaços de fala
moro sozinha anos viajei sozinha só
amiga dos meninos então pra mim eu tava
sendo de boa assim essa pauta nem é
tanto sobre mim eu nem fui capucha nem
procurei tanto saber ao mesmo tempo nas
minhas relações mais íntimas justamente
com os homens que me amavam o normal era
uma constante sensação de insegurança
sempre tinha alguma coisa de errado que
eles apontavam prontamente a roupa os
amigos
o jeito de falar o jeito de dançar
o jeito de bebê fiquem em casa tempo
demais não pára em casa ora nenhuma muda
de opinião sempre parecia que tinha um
problema eo problema era sempre eu
e aí eu me percebi muito cuidando do
morro desses homens mais do que do meu
próprio porque eu sabia que quando eles
estouravam era pior
como quando eu estava num sítio e eu
quis ficar no quintal trocando idéia com
a galera e não quis e tirar um cochilo
depois do almoço eu fui arrastada pelo
braço e arremessada para fora e trancada
para fora depois de ouvir um monte de
xingamento
quando voltei de uma viagem que eu fiz
com duas amigas e não soube explicar
roxo na perna e aí eu ouvi que depois é
estuprada bêbada e reclama quando eu
ouvi que eu tinha que agradecer porque
eu tava pegando boi porque ele gostava
de mim
apesar de eu ser do jeito que eu era
quando eu tomei a iniciativa e ouvir que
devia ser porque estava insegura
querendo provar alguma coisa ou quando
falaram que eu não me importava com
ninguém e pararam de falar comigo porque
eu fiz uma tatuagem
foram inúmeras situações assim ao longo
dos anos e eu me perceber cada vez mais
observando o meu comportamento olhando
tudo revisitando acordando no dia
seguinte passando ponto a ponto de tudo
que eu tinha feito
revisitando todas as conversas pensando
mil vezes onde escolher qualquer coisa
porque eu estava com muito medo de
cometer erros que fariam esses homens
que me amavam pararem de me amar e isso
era absolutamente normal anos
assim era o que eu conhecia e foi num
encontro com outras mulheres e ouvindo a
experiência delas que eu percebi que o
problema não era eu
o problema não sou eu
se o problema fosse eu como eu poderia
ter histórias e dois tão semelhantes a
dessas mulheres muitas que viviam em
contextos são diferentes muitas que eu
nunca nem conheci foi super difícil
porque eu comecei a enxergar onde antes
eu via mau humor dificuldade de
comunicação e piada eu comecei a
enxergar violência e onde antes eu via
em mim mesma que era uma capacidade
supercompreensiva e flexível eu comecei
a enxergar a submissão e silenciamento
foi muito doloroso começar a enxergar
essas violências por todos os lados e
percebi elas estão fortemente marcadas
em mim e foi muito difícil me perdoar
por ter permitido que essas coisas
acontecessem
porque eu também estava lá
depois disso o que começou foi um
processo individual de ficar muito
vigilantes e atenta para nunca permitir
que essas violências acontecem novamente
nunca voltará naturalizar isso não
reproduzir isso com outras mulheres
porque ao mesmo tempo que foi doloroso
foi extremamente libertador pela
primeira vez eu podia ser do jeito que
eu era estava tudo bem problema não era
eu o meu conflito pessoal que me levou a
me reconhecer como mulher me ensinou a
falar ea me posicionar mas convivendo
com outras mulheres também percebi que
não somos todas iguais às mulheres
negras traziam dores e histórias que eu
não tinha porque elas são apreendidas
também pelo racismo e eu não sou
ela também trouxeram culturas símbolos
dança referências histórias
espiritualidade que eu não conhecia
porque não havia sido apresentado pra
mim antes
começou então mais um conflito pessoal
extremamente doloroso que foi me
reconhecer como mulher branca me
reconhecer como mulher branca foi me
reconhecer parte de uma estrutura o
professora me reconhecer beneficiada por
ela reconheceu em mim comportamentos que
faziam com que essa diferença
continuasse eu comecei então a me sentir
tão culpada pelo racismo mas responsável
por ele porque houve dá a partir das
mulheres negras que se a minha intenção
não era de produzir racismo a
consequência de várias das minhas ações
era justamente essa aprofunda essa
diferença e foi muito doloroso porque eu
não quero ser essa pessoa eu não
acredito nisso
o desafio começou então a ser ouvir e
procurar entender porque nada na minha
vida me aproxima da compreensão do que é
uma violência estrutural como racismo
institucional que acontece em todos os
espaços desde que você nasce o tempo
inteiro que determina ainda que em vive
e quem morre nem o bullying que eu sofri
na escola nem esse cabelo nem um bisavô
negro nada me aproxima da compreensão do
que é racismo
então eu tenho que ouvir e procurar
entender ea partir disso olhar para o
meu próprio comportamento e tentar
desconstruir em mim essas coisas já que
ele não é a sociedade que eu acredito eu
percebi por exemplo tem uma dificuldade
muito grande em escrever uma pessoa como
negra mas eu não hesitaria inscrevê la
como ruiva porque é que associações são
essas que vão pipocando na cabeça da
gente que vai criando essa dificuldade
de dizer uma coisa que seja até óbvia
eu comecei a ficar vigilantes porque não
é natural diz construir essas coisas e
mudei a forma como eu me comunico eu
dizia mulher negra linda quando ouvia
uma voz de mulher linda ela fosse branca
porque também parei percebi na linguagem
expressões cotidianas que a gente usa e
que aprofundam essa diferença reforçando
imagens negativas
ninguém afogado nem precisa de ajuda a
não só a mega esse trabalho de pretos
são expressões corriqueiras que são
usadas de uma forma quase que
generalizada e que tem uma origem
racista e justamente reforçam essa
diferença mas eu não acredito nisso
então não podia mais falar não posso
mais falar eu crio um alarme na minha
cabeça que é faz kim e não só quando eu
estou prestes a falar faz sim eu
substituo por pessoa que dá para
substituir pessoas vai cumprir o mesmo
efeito
como eu também escuto toda vez que
alguém fala porque eu estou prestando
atenção porque não é natural pra mim é
natural é só reproduzir o que eu tô
escutando por aí o meu conflito pessoal
que me levou a me reconhecer como mulher
branca me fez aprender a ouvir ea dar
espaço porque se eu não acredito nesse
mundo eu tenho que estar muito muito
muito atenta com a forma como eu tô me
colocando pra que isso não
alimente e aprofunde essa diferença mas
isso não é fácil porque esses conflitos
pessoais
eles não são postos quando alguém fala
uma coisa é difícil e é difícil de ouvir
a gente não naturalmente entra nesse
modo de conflito pessoal nessa história
do eu
nessa história do eu a gente se fecha a
gente nem termina escutar alguém fala
isso é machismo isso é racismo ea gente
no nosso lugar de eu tô pensando o que
eu penso sobre isso que eu acho esse eu
vi isso não mas a minha amiga falou não
sei o que não é sobre eu é sobre o outro
quando alguém está compartilhando e
falando sobre uma situação de violência
que ela está vivendo ela está falando
sobre si e se essa é uma realidade que
traz estranhamento é porque essa
realidade não é sua e esse incômodo é
grande isso só sinaliza que maior
deveria ser o seu esforço de escuta para
tentar conhecer essa realidade a gente
defende baseada na intenção na nossa
história do eu mas eu não quis fazer
isso mas quando alguém está falando
sobre como a essa realidade ela não tá
falando da nossa da intenção do eu
a intenção é uma coisa particular só
pessoa que está fazendo as coisas pode
dizer qual é a intenção dela fazendo
aqui mas ela tá falando as consequências
e aí que mora o nosso maior desafio e
também a maior potência de transformação
dessa escuta a possibilidade de voltar o
olhar para si mesmo e para mudar o
próprio comportamento e através dessa
mudança começará a construir um mundo
mais alinhado com o que acredita alinhar
a intenção em consequência já que a
gente está tão firme que a intenção não
é essa
cuidar também do que acontece depois ser
responsável provocar mudanças externas a
partir da mudança de como a gente se
coloca no mundo é assim que eu tenho
feito que eu tenho procurado estar num
processo doloroso um processo que vai se
intensificando que a cada camada que
muda e outras coisas são reveladas
outros desafios aparecem mas muito numa
busca de ser melhor e principalmente
de coerência entre o que eu falo o que
eu penso o que eu sinto o que eu faço e
o mundo que eu quero construir um mundo
em que eu quero viver
e aí é preciso se esforçar preciso
vontade porque isso não é natural
pra gente é difícil ter as conversas que
a gente precisa mais fundamentalmente
ter nessa forma de se colocar buscando
mais coerência eu venho pelos últimos se
quase cinco anos empreendendo junto com
a mariana campanati imagina que é uma
organização que procura ativar o poder
de transformação das pessoas porque a
gente acredita muito no poder da escolha
como uma forma de provocar essas
transformações que a gente faz isso de
um lado conectando pessoas que já estão
nesse movimento de provocar mudanças
para que elas possam trocar aprender
juntos e colaborar e de outro produzindo
conteúdo que sejam ferramentas para
encontrar esse poder de transformação em
se exercitar essa abertura e
experimentar a ações concretas
ferramentas como por exemplo o jogo
treta em que através de personagens com
personalidades e objetivos bastante
específicos os jogadores vivenciam uma
situação de conflito com o objetivo de
resolver de forma que todos saiam
contemplados
é um jeito leve e divertido de exercitar
o diálogo e exercitar empatia como uma
forma de resolver esses conflitos que
são muitos que se multiplicam cada vez
mais a partir do momento que as pessoas
vão ganhando mais vozes que a gente não
quer voltar a silenciar ninguém porque
vós é um privilégio
a gente vive em relação e se essa não é
uma escolha que a gente tem a gente tem
uma escolha de como é que a gente quer
construir las
então isso a gente escolher se construir
uma história de nós
obrigada
[Aplausos]